thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
elia domitrescu
a man which is probably very well known
among the romanian
uh fans he is a coach he is
a football superstar and uh right now
he's also a commentator first of all
elia welcome to the show
thank you very much tell us a little bit
a little bit about your experience
around the super bad chess classics
from what you've seen yesterday at the
opening ceremony and today
uh during the first few moves i was
impressed
about the opening it was fantastic
events
i followed the speech of gary caspar of
opening speech and he was tremendous
outstanding
ximena is fantastic the press conference
when i was a kid always
elizabeth probably he was commented
the biggest matches between karpal
karpov and kasparov
and it's a big word for the participate
on this event speaking of uh gary
castrov
who was your favorite during those
matches was it gary or was it
anatoly kasparov kasparov of course
that's the diplomatic answer anyway uh
well uh tell us a little bit about
your first move you played uh d4
uh do you know anything about
constantine luculescu and his
partnership maybe
with that any similarities between that
and your partnership with george
during the golden years i asked him to
move what to move forward yeah i was him
before
and do you see any similarities between
his partnership with two players to
romanian players big strategy
you have to be intelligent you have to
prepare them and you have to the match
you have to be concentrate
you have to anticipate the movement of
the opponent and to react
is the same like in
like football like in football of course
and uh who is your favorite
during this event
well thank you very much for joining us
elia it's a pleasure for me and for
all the romanian fans to see you on the
show thank you very much
thank you back to you guys thank you
christian